[Music]
launching a podcast
my file name tells me that this is
pillpod76 happy friday
it's good friday it's a good friday
because uh god is dead but we only have
two days to ourselves you know yeah
that's very true i i'm more excited for
chocolate and bunny rabbits
uh my fire alarm's going off we're gonna
have to wait a second
um when it goes up when it goes off it
goes off like in the whole building so
it's someone downstairs
someone set off their smoke alarm
speaking of
cybernetic systems speaking of
cybernetic systems anyway we've you've
heard only two voices thus far we are a
reduced cast today
because the libs are off
uh interviewing
other libs yeah and
i i know they're hearing this and we
don't mean libs disparagingly we mean
them as pals but we're actually going to
go into the term
lib a little bit today because everyone
has a lib whether you decide to adopt
the moniker or not
and i know there's some
there's some marxio anarcho etc ests
that are going to be upset by that but
i don't make the rules yeah
it's the system it's the system man we
sound we're gonna sound like uh
like 19 year olds 19 year old stoners
that's just like
it's all the system man you can't get
out of it yeah this is like 70s
counterculture hippie language
it will be but uh it will sound like
that but it also will not be that
it'll sound like that and we are picking
up on some content we did like i don't
even know if it was last year or the
year before well this was uh i think the
last time was november 2020 we did our
our second episode on uh
autopoiesis and cybernetics and systems
theory so i thought i think
i think there's been some interest in us
picking this topic back up ever since so
uh better late than never
yeah i've had some messages from patrons
leaving who are like if you're not gonna
cover cybernetics and systems theory
anymore then i'm gonna leave and they
true to their word did
so [ __ ] out of here if this brings
you back um anyway when we're talking to
uh matt and
victor our lib our lib buddies
um towards whom we hold no ill will
however when we're talking to them the
the situation kind of determines
that there's a certain context or code
and we have to
make theoretical assumptions in order to
communicate with them as you do when
you're talking to anybody
including the
the insane claim that humans exist we
just have to accept that as given in
order to have a conversation
now that they're not here we can
dispense with this immoral and factually
inaccurate claim that humans exist
and we're gonna take this slow we've you
seen this is called volume one um we're
just gonna we're gonna get into some
systems theory
and
as critical theory
and i don't think you and i have done
like an actual post-humanism breakdown
have we is that is that right it feels
like we've talked about it but never
done an episode on it
i feel like we've done a lot of things
that are maybe like post-human adjacent
uh like the cybernetics system series
stuff um but i don't think we've had a
chance to broach this topic because um
you know we
the the four of us are like uh four big
circles and there's overlaps between it
but it's very difficult to find an
overlap that allows us to explore
post-humanism because
liberalism and posthumanism
seem to be quite opposed to one another
actually i think there'll be some ways
in which they're
actually continuous and join up
especially when we talk about a little
bit about transhumanism i think um
but we'll uh we'll get into all of that
and another thing i was just saying
before we start recording is that
you know post-humanism is a broader
kind of critical theory option if you're
if you're shopping around for your
critical theory options and you
you know you you see marxism you see
critical liberalism you see
post-humanism these are all ginormous
umbrella terms of loads of different
views and i think our
systems theory in cybernetics fits most
at home in a post-humanist kind of
framework at least some versions of it
that are out there and lumen is the the
guy that we're mostly going to be
referring to in terms of systems theory
that is a lot to say about marx but it's
not even
i guess you wouldn't call it critical he
just says like the assumptions that are
being made here are not assumptions that
i'm gonna make but way before we get
into that
um i just wanted to
start by
okay so
here's here's the story folks
i don't know why i said folks i've never
used that word before in my life anyway
here's the story
listeners
we were supposed to do a reading
um what's the book eric
uh so i've got one here called
philosophical post-humanism uh written
by francesca ferrando
so we were supposed to read this book
and i was about to read it until about
an hour and a half ago
i had an anxiety attack
not from the book
an anxiety attack i was chilling reading
my steegler and i don't think that
caused it either so i wouldn't be
admitting this on air if it weren't
topical and it is topical and i also
wouldn't be admitting it if there was a
cause or at least a conscious cause to
this anxiety attack because you know
people who
who have anxiety attacks i'm sure is
probably 50 of our listener base
um
but you know there's usually
it's usually an overreaction to
something like something happens that
you're worried about or
i don't know what do people have anxiety
attacks over tests maybe presentations
whatever it is exam times now yeah this
is high time for all sorts of attacks
so this one had no cause that i'm aware
of
um i just started heart rate goes up
breathing really fast i tried to take a
cold shower turn it off tried to like
lay down and
sleep and start counting objects in the
room to stop it it wasn't going away
and the reason that i'm bringing this up
is because lumen believes that what we
call the human being is actually a
misnomer
for three different systems and one of
those is the biological slash
neurological
so
the anxiety attack
is a feedback loop it's a positive
feedback loop where whatever aspects of
your brain i think it's like your
hypothalamus is that is that right
something like that
i've never i've never researched it
because i am uh i'm thankfully
not subject to anxiety attacks but
whatever does whatever does the fight
flight or fl fight thing oh yeah you're
sort of a lizard lizard brain parts so
it's supposed to moderate
um your the way your brain and body
functions and make it so this does not
happen and then
every once in a while it [ __ ] up so it
[ __ ] up
and my brain my body thought i was
i don't know running from a from a wolf
[Laughter]
and uh decided to panic for no and again
i want to stress i'm not worried about
anything
i was chilling
the week's coming to a close got some
got some plans this weekend
nothing set this off and often there is
something that you can point to to set
it off
um but this shows for
like a systems theorist that there is
this
disjunct and of course system siri is
not the only thing to say this like uh
all of psychoanalysis assumes that this
is the case but these are separate
systems that are coupled but they are
not the same
system
yeah they don't they don't communicate
with each other in in
the way that we would imagine that they
do
but yeah you can picture the mind even
as divided between the conscious and
unconscious parts and even the
unconscious parts probably have
subsystems just like the biological
parts do right we have our
our immune system our circulatory system
or skeletal muscular systems all those
different i think there's about seven of
them
all those systems are all self-enclosed
and they they they communicate with each
other okay you can say that in a
colloquial sense but if you want to use
the term communication in the technical
sense then they do not communicate with
each other directly
yeah we're going to be saying a lot of
things that sound extremely alien but
they're kind of particular
to this discourse but like like there
are no humans in society
yeah in fact there are there are no
humans at all and that's
what what social our social systems are
are not made up of people
a very counter-intuitive claim
um yeah and i don't i don't really like
discipling my relation to most theorists
as anyone familiar with my content will
probably know i like assembling these
mosaics of thought following
different lines and kind of
making making pictures making aesthetic
coherences out of them
and usually i like some bit and don't
like some bit and uh use the parts i
like and not the parts they don't now
lumen underrated
i think he's probably right like
about a hundred percent of the time
rounding up of course
um
but i don't talk about him too much
because he breaks one of my number one
rules which is don't be boring
um he is boring af
though mind-blowing so if you're
thinking oh this is a five-star review i
definitely gotta pick up social systems
uh fair warning it will make no sense
and it will be extremely boring and it
will take up a lot of your time
yeah actually there is one book that i
can recommend that kind of
it's fun is uh reality of the mass media
have you have you had a chance to crack
that one
no it's on my reading list this guy i
mean the guy wrote so much like he his
output was just unbelievable he wrote
something like 50 or 60 books in his
lifetime like and and then
like hundreds of articles on top of that
the guy was a machine
so now we get there yeah exactly you
remember when they found his like office
after he died and it was just like
one billion
index cards with all of his notes on it
oh that's another thing that might be
fun to get to too his uh his zettel
casten system has i've actually tried to
sort of reproduce it a little bit but
that's that's that's getting ahead of
things
yeah let's not get ahead uh
because we haven't talked about it in so
long uh you might want to refresh her on
those episodes and this is volume one so
we don't have to
even attempt to cover
uh lumen today i think the the other
boys have another interview
uh next week so we might just we might
just uh split off and do our own thing
for a little bit
um so this book by francesca is it
ferando ferando yep
what are we what's our intro to
post-humanism when we are looking at
that book right so
francesco ferrando um who's a
professor of philosophy assistant
prophet uh
nyu
um
she's got she's got her own version
called philosophical post-humanism which
is the title of the book that she wants
to sort of elaborate and articulate like
philosophically but it
it
sort of gives you this really helpful
overview
of post-humanism and all the sorts of
varieties
and what things post-humanism is like
and how it's different from the other
things
so it's it's just a great book to get
like this nice overview she begins with
a set of premises
on which post-humanism
is based
and and i'm sure a lot of people are
familiar with this story you know the
the 21st century is this time where you
know
technological and biotech and
cybernetics is becoming this really
major force the development of
technology and it's challenging the um
concept of the human in all sorts of
ways and and so post-humanism is just
one of these movements that takes this
challenge very seriously
and it's it's
you know it takes place on another on a
number of levels right so
if you're familiar with the
philosophical distinctions right we talk
about epistemology and ontology for
example right so
so post-humanism takes on the human
on both of those levels so
as a kind of center of knowledge
epistemology right think you know kant
and it takes on the human ontologically
which is you know what we've been
talking about do humans exist lumen
doesn't think so they don't exist um and
it it takes it on on both of those
levels
and the human does exist on the level of
semiotics of course
which is why we have it as a word the
question is whether
it's a good or a bad concept and the
goodness or badness of a concept
is based on whether it describes what it
purports to or not
and and other levels too the level of
praxis as well
so the book just opens up with that sort
of um these premises and then goes into
making the big conceptual distinctions
so there's a lot there's a lot even to
talk about probably even before we get
to those sorts of things what kinds of
post-humanism are out there and
what is and is not post-humanism is it
different from transhumanism is it
different from anti-humanism yes and no
all those sorts of things
and just to give maybe the listeners
something to hang their hat on because
you've probably never
unless you're in in the lit never heard
a claim like there are no such things as
humans
because your answer to that is probably
i walk around i see them i'm listening
to a human right now i
know their names
how can you say there's no human
um and maybe
maybe one different way of seeing that
is uh it has a model right so when we're
talking about the human it's not like
your dad and your mom it's the concept
of the human
because you go around your life
in a day
doing a whole bunch of different stuff
you might go grocery shopping you might
get on the subway
you might uh have a conversation with
your your roommate or partner and you're
doing all these different things
and
what lumen says about the system or the
human being is like we use this as a
glue
to unify all of these disparate events
that don't actually go together but
because we're the one experiencing it
we're going to use human as a glue to
say that one agent one individual is the
cause of all these different actions
that happens
and then we go further up from that
society is made up of these individual
humans that do all these different
things but if we take a
a post-human an example of why this
would be incorrect
is
to unify like the act of tapping your
credit card on a machine
that's a very different type of action
than having a conversation with somebody
and we assume you know i'm a consumer i
buy
and then i go have a conversation
there's no disjunct there but what
lumen's going to say is don't look at
the person as the center of both of
these events
look at the systems that they are a part
of so we're focusing we're shifting
decentering if you want we're focusing
on the whole system so with credit card
it would be an entire financial system
you know the the credit card
after you after you pay then whatever
your your mastercard or visa
goes wherever it goes obviously we don't
know [ __ ] about that
but whatever happens that's its own
thing and it only views the human what
we call human in quotes now it only
views the human as this like
input source
it doesn't care who you are it doesn't
care about the rest of your life it
doesn't care about the conversations
that you have and lumens gonna go on to
say with post-humanism you could do this
for
any communication that you undertake in
the world there's nothing
there that unifies the acts of
communication all there is
is acts of communication
so we're shifting here another thing
you've probably heard me say very often
we're shifting here from an on ontology
as you mentioned of things
to an ontology where there are no things
there are only events
and there are patterns of events there
are systems of events but there's never
like one fixed thing that we can put at
the center of the whole system and
that's kind of what the post in
post-humanism means we're not going to
have
one individual agentic
at the at the center of every event that
constitutes what we'd call in everyday
terms our our normal life sorry i went
on for a bit no that's good and just to
reinforce that
yeah in any given day right you interact
with a number of different systems
as we mentioned if you go to the store
and go shopping right you know financial
systems but you're also engaged with
transportation systems or if you drove
to the store right you engage with with
infrastructure and
and vehicles and or if you're walking
you're you're engaging with this sort of
infrastructure of the sidewalks and
and and you also seem to you know
take on all these different roles
in a day right you're a student that
you're a son or a daughter or you're or
you don't fit into either of those sorts
of categories you
and we and in any any case and all those
roles you think if you if you peel back
each one student teacher
child parent whatever once you pull off
all the roles you might assume that
there's going to be something left there
called the human
some kind of being some kind of entity
called the human
and of course this is very important for
liberalism because this sort of human
with all the these sort of accidents and
roles peeled off of it the human is what
is where rights are supposed to be right
human rights
and of course
we know that
human rights
and this discourse immediately ran into
problems of excluding women right so of
course was it was it wollstonecraft
wrote like the declaration of the rights
of of women as a kind of counter text to
the declaration of the rights of man
but in any case it just goes to show you
that there that there really is a kind
of
problem at the heart of
what we're talking about when we're
talking about the human who does it
include
who does it exclude is it is a human
like an onion
with all these different layers
or i guess i guess that's a bad analogy
because onion is just layers yeah but
but like as a human like a fruit
the human is the seed and all the layers
and things outside of it are like the
the roles and accidents and different
things we take on the inessential parts
and that but again we assume that at the
bottom of all that there's something
left over called the human
but i mean you could think about when
you and then when you look at the human
you're like oh wow actually there's a
lot more going on there there's all
kinds of biological and psychological
conscious and unconscious
speech related and non-verbal related
things going on like there's all these
sorts of different things right and
again out through all this
you know the libs right they'll kind of
try to tell you that there there is
still this this human and it's this
universal thing that we all share this
humanness and it's there underneath all
of our layers
but i mean i guess the onion example is
kind of good because it's like maybe it
is just an onion all these rolls right
you just you peel it all off and there's
just nothing left it's all layers
they're all just arranged differently
and relatively to each other there's
nothing really that's a that would be a
kind of uh when we mention ontology
that'd be kind of an ontology of
relations right relations are what are
at bottom not not
things not elements not atoms but just
relations right which are
a little more insubstantial they're not
they're not material or you can't grab
them or see them or look at them but
they're there humans are not like cakes
yeah
sorry yeah an ogre
what about cake everybody loves cake
okay we're like layer cakes right
um so to i guess elaborate on that a
little bit but
i keep bringing up lumen and we're not
talking about lumen but he's just he's
just my go-to for this so i apologize
for that uh lumen thinks that the human
being
is a
quasi religious concept that's like a
hangover of of
christianity
um and as we were talking yesterday it's
not just christianity because the romans
and and greeks had a concept of
the human but it was specifically a
legal
term it wasn't a term to just describe
you know the way we would use it to
describe
everyone's a human everyone deserves
right yeah i can go over that um but i
just preface it by saying um the type of
argument that i'm gonna go into here is
is probably you know you think of it as
an etymological argument but it's really
something similar to say listeners if
you're familiar with heidegger
and his way of arguing things right
especially in in the question concerning
technology right he goes back and he
looks at these terms um
techne episteme and poesis he brings
them back to their origin so you can do
the sort of same thing with humans right
so you know anthropos right anthropos is
the greek
origin
of the term human you'd say anthropos
had was you know
a free property-owning
non-slave male greek citizen who lives
in a city
athens or thebes or whatever
and is able to vote on issues as a
democracy
and importantly in order to be an
anthropos you can't be persian you can't
be egyptian you can't be
celtic or
or
etruscan or whatever there was around
during the classical era you can't be
any of those things you have to be greek
it's a very exclusive concept
and if i'm remembering correctly
um when when roman times came around
especially like the hellenic era
we really had this this influence from
cicero and this idea of humanitas
right and and they got this concept the
uh sort of the the hellenists who really
loved greek culture right in rome
uh not like cato the elder who was more
of a conservative he thought the the
hellenic influence was going to corrupt
the roman minds but the um these sort of
progressives were picking up on greek
ideas and translated anthropos as as
humanitas right which was famously
rediscovered
in the um renaissance era as well and
our education system is also built on
this they got their concept of the human
needs to be a kind of educated
virtuous
rational being right and didn't the
didn't the romans actually extend
citizenship to the greeks because
they're like they're they're enough like
us yeah i think so because the roman
empire was very smart about you know
what how to how to with withhold whether
or not to withhold or extend you know
humanitiness
to people right so their conquered
peoples they would be able to extend a
kind of roman citizenship to them
because it was a strategy for keeping
them from rebelling against the roman
empire because it was so big by that
time right
this came with rights being a roman
citizen gave you rites of passage i
think you couldn't be crucified since
it's good friday today you couldn't be
crucified if you were a citizen have you
heard that or am i yeah there were still
certain exclusions from this even this
sort of pan-hellenic humanism that came
out of the sort of ciceronian tradition
yeah they were big exclusions
i think i remember that because uh paul
paul the apostle
he had a greek parent one of his parents
was greek so he had citizenship and he
wasn't allowed to be crucified like uh i
think peter was crucified upside down
in the location of the vatican anyway so
what we're getting this might sound like
tedious but
we're the origin of the human it doesn't
mean
that there is no human yet like we
haven't proven that we haven't given a
convincing argument i don't think but
we're starting to
uh but the the the first versions of
of human before
uh christianity at least is that
it's a legal designation
and a designation as we know from our
our friend mr derrida any designation
has an excluded
other side to it so we are excluding
you know uh jews from the roman empire
we are excluding women we are excluding
people who don't own land and giving
rights based on you know parentage and
this is what's basically called
anthropos
you know fast forwarding probably to the
most relevant part of the story the the
modern concept of human was was born in
the enlightenment right as as
foucault
is very famous for saying in his book um
the order of things
is when that's the human is a recent
concept and
it's
probably on its way out he says
the very last
very last page of order of things
doesn't he say it's like a
a face
in the sand or something then the waves
come and wash it away
a very very controversial sort of
statement but one of the founding sort
of moments now that we now that we're
talking about post-humanism you point to
that as one of the big founding moments
um
not to say it's been interpreted in the
same way uh by everybody but um
yeah that's one of the important kinds
of statements and
and it helps with this sort of
genealogical or archaeological approach
to excavate where
human came from rather than taking it as
a uh as a taking it for granted
basically as a sort of
common sense concept
which you know is fine you walk around
you do your life you common sense gets
you by you don't need a concept of the
human
to interact with your fellows any more
than like a dog needs a concept of dog
to interact with other dogs but
but
it's uh it's quite important when it
comes to organizing society and
political life right because we need
formal definitions we need concepts we
need
things from to derive things from right
so you know
legal systems political systems economic
systems we think that the human is all
important for these things but as we've
been saying with illumine actually
actually they're not and they all sort
of have their own version of what we are
when we do interact with them you know
like i was saying before to the sidewalk
where pedestrians to the transportation
systems were just you know users
of the transportation system and it has
its own sort of version of us or even
today big data right we're just a
collection of data points we're not
really
humans you might assume that there's
some kind of
human behind it all but really it's
we're just data points to that system
because it's irrelevant our
our fleshy and angst-ridden existence is
completely irrelevant to those systems
of marketing and data brokerage
yeah and this is a kind of a technical
version of
of what al tusair
talks about like to to the criminal or
to the justice system i mean we call it
criminal or justice
probably a misnomer but to that system
you are either a law-abiding citizen
or a lab breaker someone who has broken
the law like there's no in between
you're only one of those two things it
doesn't care about the rest of your life
to the legal system you are irrelevant
until you actually have to interact with
it and show up in court so it observes
you
but it doesn't observe you all the time
and kind of what lumen is trying to get
away from is this sense that there's a
view from nowhere
uh which humanism
needs there's a view from nowhere that
it will see you at all times
as the thing that is doing all the other
things
but if we look at systems theory you are
observed only while you're interacting
and then you might as well disappear
from the face of the earth we we call
this system
versus environment the system's
interested in you while you're
interacting with it and then after that
you don't exist and systems theory is is
i mean
we covered this again i'll just say
again we covered this um in a couple
episodes about two years ago so it'd be
cool to go back and look at those
because this isn't exhaust post-humanism
it's a
for me it's it's an important part is
what i'm interested in because i'm i'm
sort of persian into persian semiotics
and i'm very interested in cybernetics
and systems theory and i found that
post-humanism is is an interesting place
to sort of position those interests
because it is like i said very broad you
can do it in different ways you can be a
techno feminist like donna haraway or
karen barad's there's two big names in
the field for example and
there's all sorts of different
approaches that run through the all of
this but i'd i like to give the sort of
story if i can indulge myself a little
further
of um again
the sort of uh i guess chinks in the
armor of the human concept um came
slowly but surely over the years um
one of the major blows
was probably
you know galileo um
you know
everybody assumed that the sort of
earth was the center of the universe and
by extension the human was the center of
the universe and everything was
organized around us in spheres right
that old
ptolemaic model um the geocentric model
and and and you know galileo blew
everyone's nips off with his his uh
his copernican model
and he got in a lot of trouble for it uh
but well that was one of the first blows
right the human is not the center of the
universe actually the sun is and
actually the sun isn't it's just one
star among many and
i would say
a few more blows to that this concept of
the human came about with um
with uh first with darwin
and the idea that
humans are not
you know
well we're not created by god or not the
crowning achievement of creation
we basically develop through random
mutation and selection right we're
random products of the
evolutionary process which we share with
all living beings
and
you know this is that this was very
important point too because some people
act like you know evolution just stopped
at human beings like okay
i don't know i don't know how you can
really think that if you if you're into
darwinism unfortunately darwin is is
sort of a um
a black sheep when you take a humanities
education darwin's not not a huge focus
but i think that's changing but then
to keep this story uh rolling um marx
probably was the next sort of blow to
that right
that that we have a kind of political
unconscious we sort of have a
conditioning based on our position in
society our world views are influenced
by
things that are outside of our control
we don't choose the world we're born
into or the class we're born into but we
certainly look at the world through that
lens once we have it
uh so kind of socio-political
unconscious you might say just like
darwin's kind of biological unconscious
i could call it
and another one with freud right we're
not rational and in control of ourselves
we're not present to ourselves perfectly
there's a part of us that's unconscious
there's a part of us that's you know
outside of our control and
and
really really influences what we do say
and think
and
again the the story could be extended
even further probably with so sir and
the linguistic turn we have this sort of
linguistic preconceitioning
that i could even bring up this sort of
sapphire wharf hypothesis where
language determines your
reality more so than anything else
so there's all these different little
you know chinks in the armor of the
human concept because as we know humans
are
rational and we speak and we have
self-control and and and all these
things are just not true they're just
not and with lumen it goes even further
right we're just we we're just caught up
in systems
and these systems don't recognize us in
any kind of holistic way they recognize
whatever parts of us are relevant to
them
and even for us we don't really know you
know like we don't really know what's
going on in our guts what's your liver
doing right now ask it how it's doing i
don't think you can
all these sorts of things right are
going on
in
i guess theory but i like to think of
those unconsciouses unconsciousnesses
anyway the biological the political the
linguistic and the psychological
all those different sorts of areas that
have troubled the human the sovereignty
and autonomy and rationality of the
concept of the human which is
what all this is supposed to be based on
and you might ask like so what we still
know what humans are right
well okay that's that's fine but i mean
you got to think the changing concept of
the human being
the idea that humans may not be around
in another million years because we've
evolved in different directions all
these sorts of things right they must
have some impact they must change the
way we think or should organize society
politics law
and maybe the way we do it right now is
sufficient
but
in the interest of being thorough and
thinking these three
these things through and having a
forward-looking kind of stance
right
these problems then sort of appear
problematic very very problematic for
for how we conduct ourselves
i don't know global warming at the end
yeah and then this is not
it's going to have no effect on your
life whether you think this way or do
not think this way um at least for for
me it kind of describes the
subjects of history are not individual
people subjects they are these massive
systems like we like to throw around the
word capitalism a lot capitalism is not
one system it's a bunch of them
but
you can't overthrow it in a day for this
reason because it's pursuing its own
interest it's using a lot of energy from
a lot of
you know people i'm referring to them
again but in this case it's just their
labor or just their
credit cards or whatever
and you can't just you know change the
world in a day because it is made up of
these systems so i want to ask you i
have the i have the ghost of victor
here eric if you're saying all this the
human doesn't matter rights are
are a fabrication that are built on this
quasi-religious outdated concept
what is the political implication of
this should you be concerned about the
political
implication um or what how does that
change your view of like should people
have a right to
free speech or right to property right
to vote do any of these things uh still
hold or do we just accept them as useful
fictions i guess i guess the answer to
that
i mean which is not super clear in my
mind already but i guess the answer to
that would be to then talk about well
what is a post-human
what is what is this post-human that
post-humanism is talking about
and what are the primary features of
post-humanism
because i think it does if you define
politics in like a very broad sense of
the ways that we sort of
live and act together and organize our
social lives
right if you if you think about politics
in this broad way
then you gotta you gotta think well like
what does politics consist of does it
consist of just human beings vying for
power okay
fine but what if if human beings are
not what we think they were
if if politics
involves things like
other systems like couplings with
economic systems and technologies right
politics was fundamentally changed for
instance by the emergence of the
televisions and the radios and the
internets and things like that right
like
if you if you're just excluding all of
those concepts and you just think about
politics consists of human beings
then like what kind of politics are you
doing right like already people like
marsha mcluhan pointed out the ways that
that even changes in technologies can
have radical impacts on all of our other
sorts of ways of of being as as human
beings right technologies
i mean he's still a bit of a humanist
when he says this but technology extends
our nervous system into a worldwide
network right the global village the
internet it our nervous systems are all
i mean almost lumen
lumen might not say this but mcluhan
would they're almost literally we're all
connected to each other by extensions of
our nervous systems today now if you
think politics shouldn't countenance
that if you want to go into political
science so do political theory and and
ignore those sorts of developments i
mean okay best of luck to you but i
think you'll be missing some really
important and obvious issues
right so you know you can always just
keep saying well i'm still a humanist
but okay now i'm just going to bring
technology into the picture i'm still a
humanist but now i'm just going to look
at the role that money plays because
money seems more important to politics
than people anyway
like you can okay you can keep sort of
extending the boundaries of what you
consider in your humanist frame over and
over again but instead of doing that
let's just take a post-humanist
perspective and see if it just works a
bit better
yeah so
there's not really a a politics that is
necessarily connected to
this kind of thinking it's more of a
a shift in model so if you think of all
of all of society as just a group of
individuals that's one possible model
and if you take this different
approach
uh your sense of it changes the look of
it changes and there is a specific term
for this in
systems theory which is called
observation
um so you're basically when we're
talking like this we're reproducing the
entire system
into a conversation so it becomes
represented
and
this is gonna get i think a little bit
galaxy brained
a little bit but if you take the human
out the human's not the model then we
get into some weird
statements statements like
people do not change their physique
the system changes physiques people do
not change tastes the system
changes tastes and this is not
giving all agency like your life is
completely determined or anything like
that but you don't really act outside of
a system
even while you're [ __ ] on one that
you don't like so our on our internet
politics uh getting names on getting
names for ourselves like
i'm a marxist
i am a
whatever ist i'm a liberal
we're all liberals because the system
itself
is liberal you don't have a choice to
just not be the thing that you have to
act out
uh because you do act them out like
whether or not you want them in this
country
you have
the right to free speech you don't get
to decide
whether or not that's true it's just
it's a function of the system that you
cannot be
tried for you know saying most things
most of the time
um and being a radical politically if
you want that's part of the system too
like the system needs radicals and then
it shifts you are you are inputting
your desires into the system you might
change something you might not you
basically need to have the biggest crew
to be able to change anything and that's
just something very obvious about
politics
but we make these divisions all the time
like what we're doing here we're we're
alternative media
we're not mainstream
media but we are mainstream media you
used exactly the same process to access
this podcast that you would to
access what's a lib podcast uh
pod save america or something like that
we use exactly the same method there is
no inside outside it's all the same
circle one way to say
there is only really liberals and
conservatives in our world is to just
look at you know the american political
system for example right it only
recognizes two positions it recognizes
democrat or republican and that's it
right there's the sort of maybe more
socialist wing of the democrats there's
the more lunatic wing of the republican
party
and there's a lot of overlap between
them as well but it basically recognizes
two positions and sorry to interrupt if
you're not one of those two positions
meaning you don't vote which is your
basically your only political you're
only a political subject when you vote
if you don't vote you don't exist
you're not in the political system
so at least in at least in america i'm
not too sure but at least in america if
you want to be a socialist well the
political system doesn't recognize your
socialism right so you can't you're not
a socialist there's no way for you to be
a socialist you can't vote as a
socialist so what what can you do okay
you can go to twitter and you can be a
socialist there twitter certainly
recognizes socialists and anarchists and
it recognizes the whole spectrum of
positions
but i mean in the end what is twitter
it's a data mining operation right so
again you're just you're just a data
point then it collects all these data
points what a socialists like social
socialists like i don't know do they
like
what kind of ice cream do socialists
like that's part of the profile what
kind of
what kind of sex toys do socialists like
do they like the do they like the the
little anal thing on their dildos or
they're just like straight dildos i
don't know like all those little little
points right they you're just a bunch of
data points so twitter recognizes you
but where does that get you they like
the whip for sure
yeah they like the cat nine tails they
like the submission
me i prefer to go to the swamp and pick
out those and never mind i and in canada
you know okay our political system does
recognize you a little bit because you
can vote ndp you can vote new democrat
they're kind of socialist although
they've kind of moved away from being a
labor organization party or you can vote
green right there's okay you can do that
in the states too right the green party
has become extremely important all
around the world and then in
european politics okay they recognize a
slightly larger
um
spectrum of positions but they're i'd
say even in that case they're basically
organized along the liberal conservative
spectrum
even though you sort of have the
the fringe parties on both sides
so that's what we mean when we say
everyone's a lib i do want to addend to
that claim that you can be a socialist
outside of electoral politics like if
you join a socialist organization then
you are recognized of course by that
organization as a socialist but we're
just speaking in terms of electoral
politics which is where
not a hundred percent of of power
to power in the political system lies
but almost almost all of it yeah yeah of
course i shouldn't i i shouldn't say
that because we obviously we don't want
to boil politics down to voting once
every four years but
there is a certain way in which that's
our political system that we work with
and that saying that you know politics
isn't just voting every once every four
years is is more of an aspirational than
a descriptive statement anyway uh
of course you can join the dsa you can
you can be you can join that party and
be kind of like a socialist there too
right but they aren't recognized by the
political system although they may be
soon with all these sort of
unionization pushes and if they position
themselves as the labor party that
in america that canada doesn't have then
that may change and then socialism may
be born in america but for now it's not
because it's not recognized true and
this may sound like uh the struggle for
recognition
in the sense of hegel's phenomenology or
uh kojev and that that's kind of true
but there's a word for this here and
it's irritation so with a big system
with lots of moving parts like electoral
politics you cannot irritate a system by
yourself
but because by yourself you're just an
individual input you are one of millions
and you are observed or you are not
observed if you don't participate
and there are some other esoteric claims
like this outside of electoral politics
that
for example the the system determines
your physique and what your body looks
like not your free will alone so you
have some decisions to make about your
body
but there are a lot of decisions about
your body that you don't make so if you
are healthy or not healthy
that's a relative
claim depending on what kind of medical
system your society has
if you are
fat or fit that's a relative claim
depending on
kind of what is encouraged depending on
how the system observes uh how precise
the monitoring systems are
whether or not healthy food is
accessible and whether the market
uh maybe the job market for example
encourages
sedentary lifestyles or not so for
example a system
a society in which you're expected to be
a soldier
the bodies of those
subjects are going to look very
different depending on what military
technologies
you are expected to be proficient with
and that's kind of an obvious claim but
it takes the center that like your body
is up to you it decenters that and says
you know in some ways your body is up to
you but not completely
i i should preface this by saying that
i've i've
gotten this example from
some lumen scholars um
hans georg mueller is one of them
so it's not my example but yeah um
yeah for instance you know you think
about
about
i gave this example the other day where
where swamps are really good for some
reason at preserving bodies and there's
this big discovery of of of these
english longbowmen
and they noticed their physique was a
lot different right
um i don't i don't even need to go to
that you know there's the old sort of
myth that the ancient amazons used to um
used to cut off one of their one of
their uh breasts so that they could fire
bows better
now
now in a sort of liberal framework you'd
be like okay well that's an individual
decision that somebody made to become a
soldier and they they knew the risks and
they knew what they had to do okay but
from a social systems theory kind of
perspective
that it's the system that's shaping
you know the
the war machine
the system of of of imperialist violence
was what shaped
you know the body of the english
longbowmen or the body of the amazonian
warrior right
the the system shapes your body right
i mean i
there's so many examples you could think
of too i i always think of i always
think of the industrial revolution as
reducing people to you know doing a
single motion over and over and over
again and then i walk into the gym and i
look at all these machines and look at
people doing single movements
along a very prescribed
arc
over and over and over again and that's
a sort of again the the the
gyms are a kind of system that shape
bodies just as just as
the pharmaceutical system is a kind of
system that shapes our chemical
constitutions and you don't make these
decisions other people these decisions
are made in a system that you're not
sort of a part of
but you're in a way
being
in a social system
means there's a certain homogeneity
to
what is recognized as an act in that
system yeah so well you could becoming a
subscriber to a gym is going to shape
your body in certain ways whether or not
you go to the gym or complain that you
hate the gym and you could you could say
again as a
the humanist would say you know this
person
decided that they wanted to be healthy
so then they went out and purchased the
gym membership and this was all
like up to them
to do
but why
could someone 400 years ago not do that
there was no system for it there was no
like i guess we could call it a cult of
health there wasn't a celebrity culture
and an instagram that rewarded that kind
of behavior so you didn't need to go to
the gym you also didn't need to go to
the gym because you didn't live a
sedentary life yeah if you were most
people
so the whole the whole gym
health system the the food you could
talk about micro plastics like you
didn't choose to put micro plastics into
your body that wasn't that wasn't a
decision that you made to
murder your sperm but if they dig up our
bodies they exhume us and like
in in the future and try to figure out
how did this society live why were they
[ __ ] eating plastic all the time
these these morons but again you dig up
the the remnants whether it's i don't
know longbowmen you dig up these ancient
civilizations that they didn't get there
and they don't look like they do because
of a whole bunch of individual
choices
or at least uh human choices they got
there because of
systems
choices
the the english army needed longbowmen
for whatever [ __ ] reason to to
because they could shoot arrows far
enough to penetrate the armor of the
french horses or whatever it is like
there's a systematic reason
that these guys have completely jacked
right arms
yeah
yeah their sort of skeletal structure
was altered and their musculature was
all
changed around and
yeah it's a systemic thing and and even
if you you know you go to the gym
and you want to achieve this sort of
body type or this sort of level this
ideal health type or whatever you think
like where did those ideals come from
right you
those were in inculcated in you from an
early age through media
today is the sort of universal way we
get ideas but you even think of ancient
greece right like those those olympian
bodies right those were that was that
was another sort of social framework
that instilled a certain ideal in people
and of course if you're a greek male you
could participate in the olympic games
and there's a certain reason for that
too and they didn't choose it that's
that's just how their society was sort
of set up and you become a part of that
you're born into it there's not much you
can do about it
uh you can try to
sell a self-critique and and try to
escape some kind of ideological
framework but and that's not sort of
social systems theories approach to that
you don't yeah sometimes you know
individual agency gets lost in this sort
of perspective
but
yeah yeah i just i do want to push back
on what we're saying here uh from what i
think people might be hearing
we're saying that on the one hand
there is a various objection that like
no look i actually have the free choice
to go to the gym or not go to the gym
which yeah that's true
so the system does not determine which
choices are made
but systems do determine the available
choices that can be made and create
channels
and incentives especially for different
types of decisions
so
to argue that the ultimate core of your
decision making is somewhere inside you
somewhere inside your humanity
that's wrong it neither begins nor ends
with you you are channeled whether or
not you participate
so if you decide to go hard in the gym
and get super cut then you'll probably
be seen as
some model of fitness and be seen as
self-disciplined you're advertising that
lifestyle you could say but
quote-unquote healthy lifestyle
is not something that you came up with
you're buying into a selection process
that now also
makes you
i don't know
become a consumer of protein shakes you
know
same thing with healthy or unhealthy
that's a distinction you're not observed
as being a healthy person or an
unhealthy person until you go
to your doctor or trainer and then they
start giving you feedback about what you
are
and then in in a hundred years when your
body is exhumed they could observe your
particular musculature or whatever
pharmaceutical chemicals are in your
hair and skin because your doctor told
you to take them and then they'll decide
what you are
in one sense but to ascribe your
musculature and the chemicals in your
body
your diet these are only in a very
limited sense
freely made choices so
to sum this up i guess if you dig up an
english longbowman and do an autopsy
um and then if you were to be dug up in
the future and if there was an autopsy
done on your corpse the differences
between
you and the english longbowmen are not
explained
by individual decisions
they are explained by
systematic
differences based on the interests of
those different societies and the
different interests of those social
systems
so the model is a shift
of where agency is located it's not in
your person
nearly as much as it is
in
the systems and their incentives and
kind of what they channel you and push
you to do in a society yeah
yeah i mean it's sort of in a way that
you're right yeah it's not deterministic
it kind of cuts through that freedom
determinism kind of
binary right because the system
the structures that we deal with do
proscribe a kind of range of choices and
we don't really have
control over what our choices are going
to be we just have to choose
or we can choose not to choose
which i don't know i don't know if
there's room for that in in lumens books
there is like if you choose to not go to
the gym then you're choosing
to be unhealthy you know if we buy that
if we buy that logic you are either a
healthy person or an unhealthy person
um and you don't you one not making a
choice is a choice
in that sense yeah i mean like maybe
your doctor tells you that your knees
are bad and you should start going to
the gym or maybe your friends got you
into following some influencer on
instagram who made you feel bad about
the way you looked and
like i mean is that and then again is
that your choice you bringing that
energy then to a gym and then you
and then you couple with some other
system is that really your choice
i mean the freedom determinism binary is
kind of irrelevant and that's that's
part of the point of systems social
systems theory anyways to cut across
these binaries
freedom and determinism the whole and
the parts this and that right identity
indifference there's there's sorts of
binaries we tend to
have in in other frameworks anyway this
is this is sociology too so it's not
it's a scientific approach to the study
of society
so naturally you're abstracting yourself
from your personal everyday existence
and you're trying to you know offer a
what lumen would call a super theory all
right it's a
it's it's not it is universal in that it
has pretensions to be universal and
explain what is common to all social
systems
no matter what type
and then you can go look at specific
more specific social systems concrete
systems like the the banking system in
the united states or something like that
but first you have to look at okay
what's common to all social systems
and then even more general just systems
in general right and then you get into
things like you know modeling systems
using
category or set theory as well which
would be an interesting application
yeah so that that's a little bit too far
yeah we we've talked about all that
before also so if you go back to
whenever systems theory was
uh we talked about that but the
post-human part of this
is that there are no
humans in society
only like certain events
and
the reason that humanism
seems so irrefutable
is because each of us
has a personal individual memory
that links your entire day together you
know like i i woke up
i ate breakfast i got onto the subway i
went shopping i bought my groceries i
came home sat on my computer for four
hours and then went to bed so you have
this memory that links all these things
together so that's your internal
experience of yourself
however you don't have that same
experience of anyone else except for you
so what humanism does like the reason it
is so successful is because everyone
every human
does have that
memory link that glues all those
different events
together
and then we look at
and this is part of why we don't
think of
like dogs as persons
because
we've never heard a dog
link all of the events in a day
together but if you talk about it from
the perspective of the system
all what happened in a day is someone
bought something at the store
someone boarded the subway and then got
off of the subway they don't care that
you think
that
there's this contiguous
person at the bottom of all of it
so
what we call it's called second order
observation um if you're a lumenian
person
but
getting out of that universalized
sense that because i have memories that
link me together
that must mean that every person also
has those and you know
they probably do
but it becomes kind of a misrecognition
in what lumen says like if we're
actually looking at the material here
you wouldn't see
an ultimate unity you don't see an
ultimate glue just like we don't see an
ultimate unity in dogs we say dogs
run on instinct
rather than like free will but we give
ourselves free will because we have
special access
to
our own system that links
our life
together into a hole and kind of what
lumen's saying is if you look at this
from the outside there's not actually a
whole that's a fantasy that you're
carrying over and that's why he calls it
a quasi-religious unity and this breaks
down all the time
for example
my panic attack that we started this
with that broke down i didn't choose
that i don't know why my
my body was making these decisions that
affected my
my self narrative my story of myself
that i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do this
reading today so i'm prepared for the
podcast i didn't choose that but i would
ignore that and say okay that
that was not me that was something
different that was my body and it's true
that it was my body
and a different system
but we have to
question
this universalizing
sense that because we experience
ourselves as a unity through memory that
everything is like that or that that's
the basis of a political system
sorry that was i was longer than i
thought it would be
no i can i can i can definitely relate
to that
and like you know i'm i have this i have
this disability or disorder that the
psychological and the pharmaceutical
systems recognized as attention deficit
disorder atd
and it's not like i'm
i'm a human being plus add or something
like that or i'm less than human when
someone has a kind of disability like
that but
it's something that's beyond my control
i don't know is addd or i don't know
what it is i don't know how it works but
i'm told that if i take something like
ritalin
it'll correct the chemical imbalances
that are causing this issue and i can be
fully human once more now i can be i can
i can cope with that sort of strategy
but again i can
this this framework of of the posthuman
is
broader than the human right the
post-human
tries to include everything that the
human excludes
i think there's no there's no the human
minus this that this that the human is
just what it is
so yeah lumen will still talk about
humans for example but from the system
perspective so one of his radical
statements that we like is uh
is humans can't communicate all right
that's very strange certain
counter-intuitive claim am i not
communicating
with pills and in the future our
listeners or i guess are you
communicating with me in the past by
listening to me
well
according to lumen no not not really
because we have to distinguish
what pills was just saying
about our personal memory that's your
that's your consciousness your psychic
system which is a very different thing
from the social system and a very
different thing again from the
biological system right those systems
are
interconnected in a way
they're they inter penetrate one another
they are coupled but they do not
communicate with one another so i
i i right now this this system that we
are a part of this this sort of internet
podcasting system is constituted by
communications if those communications
stop then this whole system would just
cease to exist it's a process it's a
pro-sexual kind of framework as well
right so yeah we have to again the
humans can't communicate is is uh a
provocative statement just meant to draw
attention to that fact the difference
between the consciousness
system or the psychic system and the
communication system right or and i
wanna the social system i'd like to
elaborate on that if i can um
if if i could
so you're hearing my voice you're
hearing eric's voice you're thinking
you're probably reflecting on on what
we're saying but if i were able to
actually communicate with your mind i
would be able to think your thoughts
but because i cannot think your thoughts
i can you know send these out i'm
recording it into a file onto my
computer which i will upload to the
internet you'll download it and you'll
be able to hear
me and you're in your earbuds or
whatever but there's nothing direct that
gets to your mind
from language language has a has a line
there's a line where language ends and
then your thinking begins your personal
narrative that we're disrupting right
now so it's not
we i remember i took like an intro to
communications
course in like undergrad and they have
these stupid [ __ ] diagrams it's like
person a communication person b
r sender receiver or or whatever it is
but the lumen point here is unless i can
think your thoughts which i can't then
we're talking about two closed systems
that are closed to each other and they
do bump into each other like i am
getting into your mind through your
earbuds
right now but the way that you receive
that message is not direct it's a
completely different
medium we could say your thoughts and my
words are completely separate media
but also my thoughts to my words are
completely separate media my my thoughts
themselves cannot create vibrations in
the air so there's a translation
happening there between
two separate things
yeah that's the the old syst
information theory perspective of
senders and receivers isn't going to
help us here because lumen kind of
dismisses that but yeah yeah i have a
certain
information that i want to convey
and i select certain utterances because
in order to convey that information
and i and i communicate right
and you you hear this communication
you also have language you also have a
sort of meaning system in your mind
and you can try to divine the message
that i was trying to send to you
i don't know if you got it or not and
you don't know if if
what what you made of what i said is
what i really meant you're never gonna
know that but
you may respond listeners right you may
like this
podcast you may even comment on the
comments section and thus you now have
selected some information of your own
and chosen an utterance for it and then
we look at it
and we judge whether or not you got our
meaning
right and we say oh this person
misunderstood us or oh this person gets
us yeah man and so
and then
we could then further respond to your
communications and then you could see
whether you got what we got what you
were saying like that's more how it
works rather than you know i don't beam
an idea directly into your brain and
then you beam it back that's that's a
little more that's a little more like
i mean that's sci-fi obviously but
that's more what the information theory
model actually wants to say in a certain
way right you
i'm a sender you're a receiver
and there's a reduction of probability
in in the message
i mean okay that works for maybe
machines but not for people yeah so
these aspects uh they're called
structural couplings these aspects
become the focus like where
where does a person interact with the
legal system what what
part of them is involved and brought up
into that when the legal system decides
uh you're a criminal
those are the kinds of points that are
of of interest so really
nothing in the world changes
by being a systems theorist except
your perspective
um so we're all looking at the same data
and humanism offers one
explanation for it
and posthumanism offers
a different explanation on it and
there's like
at least four kinds of uh of
post-humanism and they're gonna focus on
on different things uh some are gonna
focus on the animality of human beings
like there's no distinction between uh
human and animal we are animals
or they'll focus on like there's no
there's no such thing as a naked human
because the the human is always
imbricated i think is the academic term
for they're imbricated with technology
there's no human outside of its
techniques uh writing for memory for
example
all right so i think uh that's a a
pretty good
a pretty good way to wrap it up um
this is
it's not i wouldn't say it's effectual
but it is quite a radical
way to think like lumen himself says
i'm the
you mentioned the three disruptions and
he says that he's the fourth one of
those
uh you mentioned uh what is it
copernicus or galileo darwin and he says
like this is
this is the disruption that really
knocks us off of the
high horse
in which we're still the center of the
world
and it's just because the vision in
which we're the center of the world is
wrong and that's kind of why i
identify with this a lot more than with
humanism because i just think it's
it's more correct
it's more correct that i'm a series of
events fictionally woven together then
you know the world is up to me the world
is what i make of it i am
important and special and what i want
can actually happen out there in the
world that doesn't seem to be the case
to me and maybe you're dispositionally
different and then you might not like
this so much but here it is it's your
theoretical option we could call it a
critical theory because it's
critical of
one aspect of looking at society and it
is ultimately a sociology
without humans in it that's right and
i mean take these sorts of things with a
grain of salt and do your own thinking
about them but you know systems theory
does attempt to be
i mean it's a toolbox for description it
doesn't attempt to be normative it
doesn't want to make moral judgments it
doesn't want to prescribe what should or
shouldn't be done
and and in in a way lumen is seeing a
lot of modern theory as being
very normative and we've of course
discussed this on the podcast before as
a normativity
and it's it's a really annoying thing
that keeps coming back up especially
when we're talking about liberals
but the the attempt here is to be
non-normative or maybe
not normative in the sense of moral
yeah moral because
systems are normative that's why they
work that's why how they reproduce
themselves in what's called autopolicies
by being normative
so i don't i don't know who the crypto
normativists are but we are
announcing that we are normativists
but
saying that systems are normative not
that you know morality is normative
yeah from that perspective yeah i fully
embrace normativity right every every
system is self-regulating every system
is you know as we say with autopoiesis
every system is self-creating it creates
itself at every moment right because
like i said
those it's a relational ontology so it's
composed of relations and events
atoms yeah events actions interactions
every system recognizes a different
stock or basic sort of
let's say event slash process
that has to keep on being iterated and
iterated and iterated and
composed like you know if if if everyone
suddenly stopped communicating for a day
imagine what would happen to the
internet you remember those old like
blackouts that happened a little while
ago when when like facebook and
everything else was protesting these
sorts of new laws that were coming
through they were attempting to
they were attempting to irritate the
[ __ ] out of the political system
by making this big point but at the same
time they endangered their own existence
because they ceased to reproduce
communication during that time
but it's it's a so it's a non-normative
kind of framework when you're thinking
of it in a moral sense but in another
sense it is normative because every
system has a regulatory kind of feature
right you know like the freaking
thermostat in my house regulates the
temperature it's kind of it's so it's
normative in its own way
if it if the temperature goes away from
the setting that i set it at that's bad
not morally bad not going to hell for it
much less is my thermostat gonna go to
hell but it it's just not normative in
the in the way you think of it overthrow
the thermostat hegemony
exactly put a hammer right through that
[ __ ] yeah
down with homeostasis i like
i like chaos
why don't we uh
wrap it there i hope
if if this episode is successful it
means that we have successfully
irritated your psychological system from
the outside we're not in there but we
can irritate it from the outside and
when you irritate something in systems
theory that's what brings about change
so
really when i say ideas doesn't don't
matter
this is kind of
what i mean by it it's kind of the
subtext it's the the activity
is what makes the difference
not the belief
not the and not even the speech act i
mean those do make those are
communications but you know the action
is what makes a difference if you want
to overthrow the system find the weak
points in it and uh irritate them i hope
this piques some interest anyway because
i would love to talk more about it so
just to be clear we we we approached
post-humanism and we used quite a bit of
like lumen and systems theory to talk
about it
but in fut in the future if if if you if
you want to hear more
we're going to talk more about
other features of post-humanism and
possibly go a little deeper into systems
theory and cybernetics as well because
we could very well bring up you know
derrida and foucault
and sort of so-called post-modernist
theorists because they provide a lot of
material for
posthumous thinking and actually lumen
was a big fan of dairy does and he
actually saw himself as as
as continuing the deconstructivist
project second second order observation
is for lumen a kind of almost an uh
another word for deconstruction
so it's uh
at the very least
second order
observation second order systems theory
is constituted by a deconstruction of
its central term and its central term is
system yep and we need to create a
system here so what we're gonna do
there's no really real way to uh
comment on
podcasts uh audio podcasts so i would
encourage you because we don't we don't
really know what is peaking your
interest here uh we've said we've tried
to like throw at or shoot the
provocative statements from lumen at you
just because they are so provocative
like there are no humans in society that
sounds like an insane thing to say
so what we need from you go to the
youtube channel for this podcast if you
have questions and you will decide
through feedback
the continuation of this system and
which way
it goes because i i don't know i'm not
in your brain thinking your thoughts
i'm sorry i'm not in your psychological
system thinking your thoughts your brain
is part of your neurological system so
i'm not i'm not thinking your thoughts
so if you do have questions feedback say
i want to hear more about that thing
that you brought up
we are going to do a feedback episode
and of course that goes for
the
patrons and the patron
who are listening to this as well we'll
give you we'll give you priority hearing
about that
because we need money to continue the
system also
we cannot podcast if we do not have a
house to rent and he and heat to turn on
and buy our dildos i i need a new one
mine's mine's in tatters
sorry you can cut that out but i didn't
know that was a thing but
i'm sure many of the sickos out there
are gonna know so anyway give us your
comments feedback is what creates
systems so let's auto poeticize
this [ __ ] and uh
we will talk to you for volume two
all right communication over
uber pause it's not over until i press
uh
stop on my software
[Music]
you